with those new cdc guidelines in place
gyms are now allowing fully vaccinated
people to work out without face
coverings
madison kimbrough stopped by a locally
owned gym in henderson today
where some are now able to go mask free
she joins us live with the latest
tonight
madison hey sasha yes while we're
standing in front of an lvac
right now earlier we were at proto gym
in henderson where we saw fully
vaccinated people
working out mask free so how did they
feel about it
and do they think it's too soon take a
listen
a lot of people didn't like working out
with the masks we used to have
confrontation with
customers just because they didn't want
to have to wear their mask and for me it
was like i just work here
i just have to tell you to wear the mask
ever since the cdc made the announcement
on thursday that those who are fully
vaccinated
are not required to wear a mask indoors
more and more businesses are adapting to
the new guidance
gyms in particular corporate gyms like
the ymca lvac
eos and 24-hour fitness are all allowing
their members to go without a mask
if they are vaccinated locally owned
facilities like
proto-gym and henderson are doing the
same thing proto-gym personal trainer
dylan leach feels like he has already
seen an
increase in his clientele now that masks
are not enforced for everyone
once the pandemic hit it definitely
brought down the membership a little bit
people weren't super happy about having
to wear a mask while they're working out
so we definitely
you know got a few people that had to
had to leave and we are now
actually seeing those same people that
left starting to come back now that the
masses are away
many of these facilities are not
requiring their members to show proof of
vaccination
and they're basing it off of the honor
system which can make some gym members
feel a bit uneasy
like riley vasquez i'm 50 50 about
everything it's definitely a relief not
having to work out with a mask
but there's still like a little
hesitation when it comes to just coving
in general
so i think it's just like a waiting game
in the back of my mind i'm wondering
you know is anything going to happen
because we're doing this way too fast
and at lvac and several other gyms we
mentioned those that still want to wear
their face coverings are more than
welcome to
so you know it should be interesting in
the next coming weeks if we witness
a drop in mask wearing moving forward
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now